hiya Georgie I still do the you know Tim
carry one I don't do this haven't even
attempted we're gonna watch the it
chapter 2 trailer John you excited I
sure I liked it Marvel fan boy career
someone's not super excited just go
Marvel [ __ ] wait get us dislikes John
I've John you got to do this listen
before we go into this I want to thank
everyone who's been downloading and
following us on the Stardust at thirty
second reaction reviews for any film TV
show and or trailer post micro sketches
sometimes post daily and it's completely
free to download completely free to use
I suggest you follow us first porfavor
let's get into this you feel free to
look around when I get the water boiling
[Music]
you go awesome music right do apologize
it gets so very hot here at this time of
year it's like what do you feel like you
could just about die but you know what
they say about dairy no one who dies
here ever really dies I had some cookies
in the oven before you came Steve right
there
I shouldn't impose I'm gonna know why
insist we photos are lovely Miss Carr
these are family my father came to this
country with 14 dollars in his pocket
what did he do mrs. Kirsch my father
joined the circus
Oh what about you
Oh No
[Music]
[Music]
Smith losers Club has officially begun
Wow
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
music - thank you theme song so creepy
yeah well that was cool
yeah that's neat how they kind of just
it was like a whole scene yeah it's like
they dropped you in feel like okay this
is a trailer no no this is I thought for
a second that they were just gonna yeah
end it there and then I like to you know
they can end up with like a medley of it
was like a good teaser with a scene
wrapped around I felt like when after
the scene then it got into the montage
of seeing all the actors I was like
floor watching an action movie the end
game trailer was cool like rotating shot
where they're in the glass there's kids
again did it sort of feel that way
I am a little worrisome about this movie
because I mean I've heard book readers
say the adult part is not as great as
the kid part I've never read the book
I've seen the miniseries and I honestly
do actually don't know how faithful that
is but I'm watching the miniseries I was
there going this adult stuff is nowhere
near as good as the kid stuff in there a
little skeptical but I feel like they're
aware of that criticism oh yeah and
they're gonna do everything they can to
make this you know really stand out
really shine and the main thing that's
like looking over the montage is stuff
I'm sure if you like what the frame by
frame there's probably stuff you can
pick apart here you know in horror set
pieces and moments and stuff yeah I'm
excited for you know Bill Hader to be
here and Jessica Chastain - those are
the three actors on the most exact work
maybe because of the most famous ones
that the group older counterparts
I mean like she is such a great match
for Sophia Louis oh absolutely and I
also love this scene because it's like
penny wise messing around in a weird way
because you guys I don't know penny wise
is doing exactly because you're like
what who are you messing around
stick around four at the back one of
those horror movie things where you're
like okay you're doing this because it's
a horror movie you know we can see it
yeah and that's one of those things that
I feel like is a reasonable gripe it
doesn't always bother me but it is
something where you're like ah I wish
she had noticed or something you know or
at least done one of those ah you know
oh there's nothing there yeah and the
the old person running after her kind of
harkens to the shining a little bit yeah
was he not actually thinking of that an
old lady in the bathtub coming after our
main character here I wonder if Beverly
will be more of the central focus and
that's maybe you know I think that we a
pretty neat thing to actually experience
yeah I think it would - and I mean it
certainly seems that way from their
choice of including this cliff here I
mean I gotta imagine that they'll all
kind of be an ensemble again but I think
it'd be pretty interesting if they kind
of I wonder if they're going to use her
as a means of getting back to Derry or
if everybody's gonna have one of these
moments or something or like they all
get an individual Oh we're returning
home cuz I think in the logline it says
like you know they're basically moved on
and so 27 years later and then a phone
call you know reunites them brings the
back firmer than miniseries it was Mike
it was calling everyone back okay I
think I haven't seen them in a long time
yeah yeah I mean they all feel they all
they all come back one at a time to
catch up on their lives I just don't
want it to be a thing where they're just
reflecting on the past the whole time I
want it to be very different than what I
remember because I remember in the
miniseries it was just like they just
keep talking about the past and then it
kind of just feels like a rehash of this
stuff with the kids when it looks like
they're gonna be doing a lot of things
like a lot of the imagery were quickly
flashing over did not look at too much
familiar to me other than like they go
to dinner together yeah there's a few
things that alike seem kind of familiar
but I feel like they're really gonna amp
up the set pieces this time around I bet
they'll amp up the intensity and they'll
do their best to make this just as
aggressive a horror movie is you know
the first chapter of the it remake was
because you know that's a pretty in your
face movie and so I I have to imagine
that every time somebody does another
Stephen King add up to
you know they're always tweaking
something and so like you said it just
hit me that Jessica Chastain and James
McAvoy are in this together yeah they're
doing Dark Phoenix together yeah yeah
just hit me right there you got a thorn
Valkyrie doing men in black why not get
some x-men care yeah some set pieces
look familiar and then there's a lot of
shots of them all lined up to you but I
wanted it I want to see a little bit
more of their chemistry because you know
like when you're doing this trailer
there are a lot of those shots of like
look at them as adults and then show
them as kids them as adults show the
most kids remember oh yeah I don't know
if it's like a remember thing or if it's
is a visual aid so that way look how
good our matches I mean beyond that I'm
trying to I'm thinking that not everyone
knows what the cast list is or who
they're playing so I think they're
trying to make it a little bit easier
for people to go oh that's who that
person is going dad to that person's
playing but yeah I mean this looks cool
and that scene I thought have a lot of
tension in it we even get one look at
penny wire or at least a couple but one
you know solid you know classic penny
wise look yeah you get that solid
classic penny wise look at the part
where he's tearing off his face kind of
reminds me of poltergeist a little bit
yeah see I almost wonder if this one's
gonna go kind of hog wild with it so Maj
is and stuff like that because I mean
there are a couple things yeah they're
reminded me of The Shining like you
mentioned not only with the old lady but
whatever that room is that's filling
with blood also kind of harkening back
to them oh yeah I movie with the
bathroom and all that stuff I'm hoping
it's not just this similar set pieces
but bigger yeah yeah yeah yeah like
remember when this happened to you as a
kid it's gonna happen again and the way
they did the whole thing with the dad
joining the circus I wonder if that
that's something we're gonna see a
little bit more of why of like the
origins of penny wise or why penny wise
took on that identity or something yeah
I were if that's just his tell for the
yeah the fact that he's messing with her
right now anyway guys what did you think
of this trailer comment below
before I wrap this video up I would like
to give a patron the day shadow to a man
named Derek Mitchell if you guys have
heard us shot him out before there's a
reason why we're choosing him for this
specific video because Derek is a guy
who looks friendly on the outside is
even very charismatic some might say
gregarious he's a charming fellow but
you can't trust him especially around
kids that dude is a serial killer
all right everywhere he's going he's
chopping up children left and right this
shout-out is not meant to support him it
is meant to warn you about Derek
Mitchell I don't know if he still does
like uber or lyft ride me I know he got
a job at a tech company and it's going
great for him so good for you but I'm
also warning you the dudes a real creep
yeah he travels through the sewers so if
you ever see him down there just don't
engage walk right on bass no you don't
want to get caught up if you think this
is gonna end with going no seriously
Derek's actually a great guy it's not
gonna end that way
do not trust Derek Mitchell don't but
seriously he's a creepy guy he's an odd
guy I still like him
well guys comment below subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell hit the like button if you wish and
download and false on the star to us at
pa